[Música]
bienvenidos a canadá en las américas
cafe los saluda paloma martínez estamos
aquí en montreal todavía es fernando
estudio yo sigo encantada con estos
nuevos estudios aquí en el estudio del
equipo latinoamericano de radio canadá
internacional luis laborda leonora
charla y tenemos dos invitados
especiales pedro ruiz
arantxa maldonado ambos están
presentando nos aquí en el estudio su
nueva película
arantxa como productora y pedro ruiz
como cineasta de la habana desde las
alturas la traduje yo pero no es la
traducción exacta que ustedes le están
dando bueno la verdad es que ahora
paloma muchas gracias de recibirnos aquí
en el estudio tenemos un título en
español que se arriba habana que no pues
apareció así pensando en títulos que
podían corresponder a la película pero
sin traducirlos literalmente las fue
arriba habana en español y de alguna
manera lo que vamos a estar hablando en
el momento más es justamente de esta
visión desde desde arriba de la bajar la
habana desde las alturas que va mal la
traducción que hiciste bueno
es complementaria también en el programa
estaremos hablando de una bailarina de
flamenco muy especial en urano estará
presentando su historia de facebook y su
posicionamiento contra el suprema es el
supremacismo blanco y la belleza y la
diversidad de montreal norte uno de los
barrios más pobres de canadá y luís te
unas aulas de esta semana de una
película ya también no también muy
particular
sí sí bueno aparece nuestro tema del día
nuestro nuestro tema de la semana luego
ese es un tema de los extraños mi tema
de la semana es el de una investigación
que se llevó a cabo en colombia que
tiene que ver con la infiltración de
grupos paramilitares en distintos
estamentos de gobierno y que cuestiona
un poco el proceso de paz en que si lo
pone en peligro
bueno tomamos entonces con las
curiosidades entre otras la película que
nos está de la que nos está hablando
luis laborda vamos a ver si podemos
verles el vídeo directamente y
comenzamos a hablar es una película en
lengua indígena el software es una
lengua indígena que solo la hablan hay
20 personas 20 personas piensas la
particularidad este film es una
producción canadiense
que rescata una lengua indígena que se
habla en el oeste de canadá en la
provincia de columbia británica hay
solamente 20 personas que la hablan y la
iniciativa del filme es precisamente
para propiciar la preservación de esta
lengua porque está considerada justo
junto con muchas otras en peligro de
extinción de hecho para poder hacer este
filme los actores debieron aprender la
lengua a cualquier eso no se hizo con
personas con las pero con las 20
personas que la hablan sino que se
contactó a actores y esos actores no
conocían entre dialecto indígena son dos
dialectos arraigados dentro de esa misma
lengua y debieron aprenderlo para poder
participar en este film así que el
efecto ya está
grande la objetiva de la película y
promover el nombre indígena es complicar
la cura que yo produje no sé si estará
bien la traducción como él
el filo del cuchillo porque en inglés
entonces si el filo del cuchillo se
habla en un territorio que está ubicado
en piernas de la comunidad
que están allí en una isla en el en el
oeste canadiense aislado es un poco del
resto de la comunidad y por eso tal vez
también es la lengua se ha visto de
alguna manera de expedida de poder
seguir expandiéndose
aunque como acabo de decir y eso lo
sabemos todos las lenguas indígenas en
general están en periodo de extensión
salvo algunos casos muy específicos de
lenguas que son habladas por comunidades
mucho más numerosas este fin perdón se
va a estrenar
se va a estrenar en un festival dedicado
precisamente a canadá
y mi pregunta es una película de ficción
o un documental por lo que yo vi es una
ficción porque habla de una de un mito
que tiene esa comunidad de un hombre que
se duerme y vive una experiencia extraña
a partir de ese sueño
es muy interesante porque espero que
podamos verla en algún momento aquí en
montreal cuando llegue aquí a la ciudad
muchas gracias luis y leonora tú no
hablas de una cosa que llamó la atención
esta semana para ti fue la deportación
de uno la próxima deportación que fue
decidida este viernes pasado y que se va
a producir próximamente y es una
deportación que llama la atención es la
primera vez que este tipo de casos se
produce en canadá es son dos padres de
origen latinoamericano que están hace 12
años en canadá tuvieron un niño que se
llama julián la madre se llama rosalba
solares es guatemalteca el padre es
jorge orozco es colombiano y inmigración
canadá decidió expulsarlos les negó la
solicitud de refugio que ellos
presentaron pero en vez de permitir que
la familia vaya como el principio se
pensaba todos a colombia decidió enviar
a la madre a guatemala al padre a
colombia y el niño pues me hace acordar
un poco eso eeuu en un momento dado
decían ese estadounidense es acá nadie
se puede quedar tiene siete años
entonces él va a ir con la madre a
guatemala el niño pero entonces ahí me
llamó la atención una una declaración
del abogado que los defiende el horno
world man que dijo que él hace mucho que
está trabajando en el tema del refugio y
que nunca es la primera vez que se
encuentran tengo una situación en la que
dividen a una familia separan al padre
de la madre del hijo y esto está
teniendo una connotación también más
canadiense a nivel canadiense porque
esta es el médico que lo estamos viendo
en este momento que es el doctor paul
colford que es muy conocido porque en la
época de stephen harper cuando él harper
quería cortar el acceso a la salud a los
refugiados él decidió abrir su clínica a
todos los niños y refugiados y los
atendía gratuitamente y él está con el
niño este ahora y está previniendo y
dice que hay posibilidad de estrés
post-traumático que puede sufrir ese
niño que ya tiene los síntomas entonces
creo que esto merece pues
la bendición y como dice este médico
esto lo visto no son valores canadienses
y si no no me huele a las familias
entonces iremos siguiendo la oración se
pospone y bueno hay unos temas curiosos
les hablo de un productor de jarabe de
arce en nuevo brunswick él decidió hacer
los hoyitos en los en los árboles de
arce en los arces gigantes estos que hay
en un cementerio en los argentinos
momentos entonces sentí con sabor a
huevos justamente hay muchos
cuestionamientos alrededor de esta idea
que tuvo esta persona porque son árboles
centenarios viejísimos y que además con
la manera en que se enterraba la gente
antes podría haber residuos químicos y
cosas terribles que yo no me pueden
imaginar que se incluyen digamos en esta
savia que después es hervida y
convertida en jarabe
utiliza la técnica pues bollitos con
tubitos que van jalando la savia y que
bueno se van a esta este recipiente para
después convertirlo en savia de arce en
jarabe de arce entonces bueno es uno de
los temas que me llamó la atención
porque eligen no sé si quiero probarla
el nuevo práctica en la ciudad de
shenyang en el este de la provincia
que no venga el cementerio nuevo ron
sweet bueno ahora sí vamos a pasar a
nuestros invitados les presento primero
en el trailer que es la presentación
principal de la película entonces vamos
a ver a ver si nos pueden mandar en este
momento antes de la entrevista
entonces están por presentar la película
es la película de qué
desde la salud últimos lo traduje yo
escuchar en cadena
si prefieres no te puedes controlar no
puedes durar la calma deja que él venga
balón en el mar
ya que la garrafa que llena tu mente de
exportar los pensamientos fluyen sin
cesar hasta
qué buena imagen
y
desde las alturas entonces yo así la
traduje pero es arriba la habana arriba
arriba habana dos palabras dos palabras
entonces arantxa manuel maldonado que
conocemos porque ya ha estado por acá
por nuestros estudios y por nuestras
oficinas ha trabajado con nosotros con
anterioridad ahora es productora ahora
es la última película que hemos
producido y que pedro ha dirigido un
documental largometraje que quien
representamos aquí en febrero en el
festival candy booker ex cinema y que
ahora vamos a ir a otros festivales a
sherbrooke a hot docs al final de abril
que hemos dado nuestra vida méxico
también entonces está comenzando a
viajar la habana está viajando con
ustedes pedro de donde surgió esta idea
de ir a buscar estas imágenes de la
habana desde arriba porque los turistas
no tenemos acceso a esa habana y
exactamente eso que dicen conseguir otro
aspecto de la habana que no se ha
contado o que se ha contado poco y
terminamos en ese reducto en ese pequeño
espacio en esa canopia en esa banda
lejos de los turistas más cerca del
cielo ellos mismo dicen acerca de los
dioses y el riesgo de lejos de seguro y
luego también encontramos otro otro
submundo otro mundo aparte maravilloso
cómo está cómo surgió la idea de dónde
vino la idea era hacer algo efe siempre
tuvimos latente porque una vez en una
película sobre filemón el cantante que
adecuada
su disco lo grabó de negre en eso fuimos
con él a él fue agradecer a la gente la
gente que lo ayudó a participar en ese
disco de hecho de hecho él se hizo
famoso gracias a esa grabación
independiente grabó vino y se lanzó a un
niño del primer mundo que va al tercer
mundo
césar mi realidad pero venía compañía
filmó en ese segundo viaje y con él
grabamos muchos vídeos arriba de los
techos y a partir de ahí esa cosa empezó
a estar más latente más latente más
latente que lo concretamos una lancha y
justamente iba a preguntar en términos
de las dificultades de la producción
de este proyecto cuáles han sido las
principales que nos enfrentaron muchas
muchas porque producir documentales no
es fácil desde un punto de vista de la
financiación conseguir levantar
financiación aquí que te crean con una
idea en un papel que diga no yo voy a
hacer una película voy a hablar de algo
que está que es casi secreto que no no a
nadie tiene acceso y vas una película
ser maravilloso de hacer preciosa tras
una hoja de papel es difícil que de
hecho en una de las entrevistas nos
dijeron pensando aquí vamos hacer una
película con un dron de imágenes aéreas
de uno no tiene nada que ver eso es una
historia contada desde las alturas desde
lo alto de los edificios las azoteas son
por un lado será el lado más de
financiación y por otro lado ya durante
el rodaje pues los edificios en la
habana están como están y en muchos son
bastante peligrosos de subir hay que
subir con el equipo con los objetivos
entonces tiene su complejidad y además
esta idea también un poco responde a la
cuestión de la escasez crónica de
viviendas en la habana porque la parte
central de la habana particularmente no
es la gente ha comenzado a comenzar a
vivir justo cada vez más arriba es
cierto sin duda eso sí en términos
prácticos es así hay una migración como
en toda la ciudad del mundo del campo a
las ciudades
y encadenaba fue muy presente de hecho
la gente que viene del campo llaman
palestinos delante que en el oriente y
de hecho incluso de hubo momentos en la
habana que tenía incluso que tener un
carnet para hacer habanero y una
identidad no tiene trabajo incluso ya
eso se ha ido eliminando pero de hecho
uno de los personajes nuestro dice que
los los habaneros están en miami
realmente está superpoblada estas
pobladas de campesinos de gente del
interior ya tienen más de 20 y pico de
años hay de que ya muchas deben
considerarse habaneros de ahí pero en
ese sentido esa la parte real práctica
desde un hecho histórico pero también
nosotros abrimos como un espacio un
caleidoscopio de cómo de voces y de ires
y de seres que incluimos ahí con una
suerte de cámara indiscreta sin sin
querer ser lo que invita al espectador a
la gente que está allá arriba querer ver
qué hay del otro lado de la ventana que
del otro lado de ese espacio y qué fue
lo que más lo sorprendió
desde arriba nosotros nos sorprendió
esos personajes con tanta resiliencia se
dice con tantas capacidades
como con constantes es con tanto
espíritu y con tanto deseo a pesar de lo
duro que puede ser estoy para dar un
ejemplo desafectan un cuarto de un
ascensor le quitan las máquinas y lo
vuelven una casa
y la cintita por ejemplo darme con sus
dos hijos socios de treinta cuarenta y
pico años es un espacio asignado pequeño
difícil pero si te lo cuento de esa
manera pero lo vive no son sus casas son
su familia viven con una tranquilidad
son sus islas dentro de esa isla pezzuti
está no baja pasa para que hace un año y
se inicia sociedad entonces estar en esa
isla que a su vez es otra isla con otra
realidad y con esos seres maravillosos
algunos más tristes que otros no más
nostálgicos que otros algunas con unas
historias de vida impresionante claro
que han viajado que han estado en guerra
quien fueron que han sido espía
uno de los personajes que tenemos es el
oído el che guevara él puede tener que
tocar el tambor es el hijo ilegítimo no
reconocido por lo que van
poquita que tuvo en la lucha con un
elche de la época entonces justamente
son muchas historias contadas desde
arriba y al mismo tiempo es este si es
una manera de conocer otro aspecto
completamente diferente de la habana y
escuchar claro lo que lo que la gente
como la gente ha vivido ese es esa
historia pues cubana a mí me atrae mucho
los colores de los espacios de la gente
y me pregunto cuáles eran las mejores
horas de filmar de esa fotografía que
ves es tan particular y cuando ustedes
filmaban cuál era la mejor hora muy
buena de la madrugada y al final del día
por por cosas prácticas primero porque
era muy difícil como de arantxa el calor
era muy muy fuerte llevamos equipos de
de cine muy grande para tu ejemplo un
lente pues a un kilo y medio un lente
llegábamos siete lente entonces por ese
lado y por otro lado también nos
permitía como a descansar un poco el
medio día seguir investigando tus
personajes porque los mismos personajes
ganábamos
de los personajes de la vida cotidiana
gente normal y que no están actuando
para espacios reales y desde las alturas
el paisaje que si totalmente también te
recuerda de subir el movimiento a martí
en la habana y de la cima de momento
partir la habana y lo que rodea a la
habana se ve de manera totalmente
distinta eso lo muestra nos dice en
algún momento bueno se ve la habana
desde arriba durante toda la película
son asentamientos en la que tenemos
nuestros edificios elevados y nunca
estamos nunca estamos abajo nunca
bajamos para abajo si tan complicado sí
sí como para dar la impresión realmente
que estamos muy hartos y la habana es
muy bella desde arriba es preciosa
bueno rodar durante las horas mágicas
era una decisión práctica una decisión
también una luz increíble
entonces la película comenzó a viajar
con ustedes me decía méxico y toronto
docs es el buque es el 10 de abril que
presentamos aquí la película viene hot
docs después 26-27 3 de mayo y el 3 de
mayo hacemos la salida en cines aquí en
quebec
el festival de jorge perugorría en el
actor y creo que vamos presa no hay más
que en la habana así que bueno porque es
más en más la presente y quizá vamos a
trasladar alguno de los personajes en
con nosotros porque yo no sé cómo se
ahora pero yo cuando visitaba la habana
los cubanos la gente de ahí les encanta
si se llenan y les encanta y es verdad
que son grandes conocedores de cine les
gusta muchísimo si conocedores y
consumidores de consumidores hay también
aquí varios a los cubanos bien pero son
la lengua si les gusta
pues qué bueno mucha suerte con todo lo
que viene con esta película gracias por
venir a presentarla y lo mejor lo mejor
es una es un gran es un gran proyecto
con grandes dificultades pero con cosas
fascinantes también así que adelante
pues gracias mi gracia la situación los
gracias vamos entonces a continuar
nosotros aquí con el programa tengo un
videíto para presentar en la aplicación
de radio canadá internacional en la que
invitamos a la gente a bajar a sus
teléfonos tomar a todos como a sus
tabletas tura tienes en tu tableta tengo
la impresión no tengo mi teléfono
ahorita es tan vieja que no baja ninguna
aplicación de nada ya no baja nada una
aplicación y de radio canadá y ninguna
pero en el teléfono si en el teléfono se
puede acceder muy fácilmente a todo el
contenido de nuestro sitio en internet y
es muy fácil de consultar como dice es
efectivamente se puede recorrer de
manera muy ágil los distintos contenidos
tanto en lo que hace a sonido como a
gráfica es decir fotos gráficos etcétera
etcétera bueno es también una pantalla
idénticamente
exactamente y además está claro en los
55 idiomas en canadá internacional
consultando si la aplicación atención a
la aplicación en árabe al diseño de la
página en árabe no sabe que se empiece a
escribir de derecha a izquierda
presentaría prestado atención a cómo
está ubicada la página
actualizamos la comisión de aplicación
llama mucho más atención también si yo
creo que una de las grandes imágenes la
cosa más maravillosa de radio canadá
ente ración es justamente eso que
tenemos una posibilidad de ver los
muchos contenidos no son los mismos
contenidos porque somos periodistas
diferentes todos y producimos cosas
diferentes día con día pero de alguna
manera vemos seguimos las actualidades
en los diferentes idiomas y entonces esa
aplicación nos permite tenerlo así como
ágilmente disponible para esperemos en
un futuro futuro
lenguas como teníamos hace un tiempo
atrás los cinco ya no alcanzan el mundo
es muy grande
necesitamos más lenguas además lo cierto
es que hay en la aplicación pueden
escuchar los programas ver los
reportajes ver los vídeos que
presentamos entonces todo está
disponible en la aplicación y lo
encuentran en google play o en él
depende del tipo de aparato que tengan
ustedes tenemos ahora cartas que le el
yo no sé si lazio y nos distribuyendo en
facebook o no pero por lo pronto
comencemos con lo que nos han escrito en
el sitio internet que tienen por ahí
bueno yo tengo acá un mensaje que nos
envía reina rosa castro sánchez eso es
su nombre completo sobre el tema
recuperando sonrisas un programa de
dentistas canadienses para mujeres
marginales que nos dice hola soy mamá
soltera tengo 33 años tres hijos he
pasado por poco a poco sacó adelante mi
familia soy muy trabajadora siempre mi
ingreso es para las necesidades de los
hijos tengo problemas con mi dentadura
es algo que me deprime
ocurre a mucha gente ya que no he podido
pagar para arreglar mis dientes cuando
no es una cosa es la otra pero siempre
hay algo que me lo impide ojalá me
pudieran ayudar realmente estaría
agradecida ya que me devolverán mi
sonrisa algo que hace mucho perdí y como
decimos como decimos siempre este tema
es un tema que está por supuesto
dirigido particularmente puntualmente a
gente que reside en canadá y que tiene
acceso a este plan desde el territorio
canadiense no sé si es el caso de ella
porque no lo aclara aquí si reina está
viviendo con nosotros en algún lado de
canadá por supuesto que tiene acceso a
esta iniciativa de manera mucho más
fácil si no debería ella en todo caso
buscar algún programa o como dijimos
recuerdo la emisión la última emisión
también o también de hecho donde ella se
encuentre proponer que imiten este tipo
de iniciativas eso también es una forma
de tener acceso a programas de este tipo
tengo acá algo que está justamente
relacionado con el tema que abordo louis
al inicio y el tema es es necesario que
los jóvenes se reapropien de la lengua
de sus ancestros y es un tema que no sé
no me creo quién lo hizo
escribe samuel lópez lorenzo y dice qué
idea tan buena para que los jóvenes se
reapropien de sus lenguas ancestrales yo
doy mi apoyo a este proyecto este tema
es un tema que lo hice yo es una
iniciativa de la ucam de la universidad
de quebec en montreal para precisamente
promover la recuperación de las lenguas
indígenas y la supervivencia sobre todo
de aquellas que están en peligro de
extinción
acá tengo un mensaje sobre un médico
canadiense dice que la diabetes tipo 2
es curable y alejandra vicente dice hola
buenas tardes soy mexicana hace 4 años
me dio diabetes desde entonces he
batallado mucho con mi alimentación y
estados de ánimo pero hace días que hice
ejercicio no hice ejercicio excesivo y
ahora se me está bajando mucho los
niveles de azúcar entonces dice por eso
ahora necesito estar revisando
constantemente mis niveles y estar
comiendo dulces o una porción de
carbohidratos bueno me dice me siento
desesperada porque los síntomas son
peores que la hiperglucemia será
pasajero que se me quito la que se me
quitó la diabetes pregunta ella me
imagino entonces probablemente en el
artículo que presentamos al respecto en
el reportaje que hicimos hay más
información sobre por qué este médico
canadiense era un médico de la ciudad de
toronto si no si mal no me acuerdo de
toronto y que era muy interesante porque
daba las pautas finalmente lo que todo
el mundo hable es que no sé
el mundo se va a una tasa de obesidad
nunca antes vista y eso trae el problema
de la diabetes 2 y esto es producto de
ese justamente este sobre consumo de
alimentos entonces este médico hablaba
de eso y cómo puedes eliminar esta
diabetes diabetes 2 y daba las pautas
cómo hacerlo y dice que sí que es
posible que lo han hecho y lo han
experimentado y me hace pensar en otro
reportaje que hice yo una entrevista con
un médico de origen argentino aquí en la
universidad de montreal en uno de los
hospitales de la universidad de montreal
y él decía que la fructosa que es lo que
están ahora incluyendo en muchos de los
alimentos cómo se dicen industrializados
pues están agregando eso para
reemplazarlo ha sido en carnes su
costado negro y eso es lo que justamente
está en en parte atacando al asedio
creando la diabetes tipo 2 también son
es peligrosísima muy bien otro reporte
tengo algo es muy cortito voy a ir con
esto es la pasión por la apicultura en
saskatchewan camilo carvajal dice hola
en realidad la apicultura es una
muy corto lo que no tengo corto es la
posta de inicio del programa que ha
tenido mi oído desde que comenzamos del
programa estaba el tiempo así que lo
tengo aquí un mensaje que hice plan de
canadá para traer inmigrantes a zonas
remotas del país los 9 que él y linares
hay desaparece la música muchas gracias
a nuestros técnicos quiero preguntar si
una persona es demandante ha sido en
quebec y no le han dado respuesta si
puede acogerse a este plan de
inmigración y pasar de vivir en quebec
allí directamente bueno yo no trabajé el
tema pero en principio son dos
iniciativas independientes la una de la
otra así que de hecho si pidió asilo en
quebec y no tiene aún respuesta no veo
impedimento para ese tema y no hay
ningún impedimento sector pueden venir
de cualquier lugar de canadá sólo tienen
que ser inmigrantes que van a otros
lugares y de hecho recordemos que los el
programa de refugio es manejado por el
gobierno federal no por el gobierno de
quebec a lo mejor él pidió venía a la
provincia de québec pero es el gobierno
federal que nuestro nuevo solo
refugiados
el doctor del gobierno los proyectos
exactamente tenemos un mensaje en
facebook live la gente que no está
siguiendo por facebook dice gustavo
lucas saludo desde ciudad de melo
departamento de cerro largo en uruguay
así que hoy tenemos menos mensajes en el
programa en facebook será porque quiero
porque no lo hiciera porque la gente
trabaja más hasta ahora no sabemos tal
vez la gente está adaptando el nuevo
horario
que nos digan que nos digan lo que
piensan algún otro mensajito ya pasando
y todo lo que no la voy a leer por
completo me parece muy desagradable en
la manera que está escrito el tema es
nueva caravana migrante centroamericana
llega a méxico porque había salido de
honduras y el salvador y escribe rafael
desde méjico y dice regresen a su país
gente de honduras guatemala y el
salvador aquí en méxico hay mucha
pobreza y delincuencia no hay
para ustedes para darles de comer ni
cuidarlos y hasta ahí llegó muy bien lo
que es cierto es que es un tema y las
caravanas de inmigrantes tienen unos
orígenes que son muy variados muy
complejos la gente yo yo siempre me
pregunto qué que haría falta para que yo
salga de mi casa con una maleta nomás y
me ponga a caminar hacia que te estás
muriendo de hambre o que tengan niños y
que no tengas otra y tenías que hacerlo
el tema es que yo creo que rafael está
equivocado además porque ya el gobierno
de lópez obrador el gobierno de mexico
ella permitió que se quieran quedarse
les ofrecieron la carta para quedarse
encontrarles trabajo un monto mensual
para además no lo hacía solo lópez
obrador tenía me imagino la ayuda de
naciones unidas para los refugiados y
todo eso entonces hubo como 2000
centroamericanos que decidieron
detenerse en mexico y no ir hasta eeuu
entonces la juve esta yo creo que la
ayuda está exactamente están
instalándose las claras
al principio es una cuestión de
adaptación es un país que ha recibido
las grandes de su historia pero ya casi
se quedó en méxico es porque méxico les
permite vivir mucho mejor de lo que
viven en sus lugares de origen
con inseguridad pensando en qué bueno si
finalmente si emigran por tus hijos a
tus hijos le va a ir les les va a ir
mejor que a vos
además que mucha de esa gente proviene
de países donde la presencia de bandas
criminales es muy está todo eso está
todo eso y esas bandas las generales
hacen imposible una vida normal para la
peor familia entonces ante la
imposibilidad desarrollar esa vida
normal ante la falta de trabajo ante el
problema del hambre ante la inseguridad
generalizada la gente no se pone a
pensar si va a molestar lo nuevo al otro
en otro territorio para asegurar seguro
a partir de allí se generan
problemáticas que son prácticamente
normales que existan pero
en el fondo no sé por qué nos cuesta
tanto a los latinoamericanos entender
este tipo de problemáticas cuando en el
fondo somos todos inmigrantes en américa
latina no hay nadie de los que estamos
con vida hoy en día de origen
latinoamericano que hayan nacido pura y
exclusivamente originaria de ese
territorio y uno de los problemas
centrales y tenemos unos minutitos
todavía para hablar la loma uno de los
temas centrales de esta emigración que
sale de américa central tiene que ver
con la situación de la mujer de las
mujeres en centroamérica que viven
situaciones especialmente de una
violencia que viene desde hace ya
muchísimo tiempo y que incluso me hace
acordar a una propuesta del ex ministro
de relaciones exteriores de canadá lloyd
axworthy un ex ministro y primer
ministro de relaciones del partido
liberal que en este momento dirige un
organismo internacional de los para los
refugiados y que él proponía
directamente que canadá acogiera a las
mujeres solas y si tenían niños fuertes
estaban llegando a eeuu y que los iban a
rechazar
abrieron las puertas y entonces eso
sigue todavía y la gente está hablando
de eso porque la situación de la mujer
es una situación particular dentro de la
particularidad de los todos los gente la
gente las caravanas que salen bueno
vamos ahora a hablar de los temas que
les hemos estado preparando y
presentando en nuestro sitio internet a
lo largo de la semana y vamos a comenzar
con un vídeo me gustaría que lo viéramos
íntegro es un vídeo de una bailarina de
flamenco online a la hora de 6 la hora
bailaora de flamenco que no se presentas
tú así que vamos ir viendo el vídeo y
también háblanos un poquito de ella
conversé con ella vive en barcelona y
este es un documental que se presenta se
está presentando en montreal en estos
momentos en el festival internacional de
películas sobre el arte fifa por sus
siglas en inglés en francés y que va
hasta el 31 de marzo es la historia de
la chana le dice el action a empezó a
bailar a los 15 años pero con un estilo
muy particular que es los pies los pies
es una velocidad yo lo vi entera
me impresionó la manera en que combina
el baile con el zapateo y con las manos
es tuvo que luchar muchísimo para poder
hacer llegar a hacer lo que a ellas le
apasiona siempre que es el baile a los
15 años le pidió a su padre que quería
bailar y su padre le prohibió viene ella
es gitana viene en una comunidad gitana
y ella lo dice claramente es los gitanos
en la comunidad son machos son machistas
una mujer no decide nunca sobre su vida
y ese ella hizo una huelga de hambre de
una semana en su casa y al final su
madre fue la que lo convenció al padre
de que la dejaran bailar todo esto para
decirte la pasión que tiene esta mujer y
en un momento dado bueno se casó con
quien ella creía que iba a ser su pareja
de toda la vida y se dio un algo muy
especial muy particular en un momento
dado estaba ella bailando en barcelona y
por casualidad estaba ahí peter sellers
ustedes acuerdan todos
peter sellers estaba allí con otros
estaban filmando no me acuerdo viendo
que que lo que estaban firmando y cuando
la vio bailar decidió que él tenía que
mostrarle su al mundo
a hollywood para hacer un documental con
ella
el marido de la chana le quebró las
costillas a golpes
el proyecto no pudo llevarse a cabo
porque él no quiere no quería que ella
bailará su mujer es una violencia y su
historia de violencia tremenda el de la
dependencia también hay totalmente pero
la estás la estamos viendo bailar hoy
tiene 72 años de mira
el tema es que desapareció después de
los golpes desapareció veinte años una
ausencia lamentable para toda la gente
en españa y en el mundo que podría haber
disfrutado de este arte hasta que
decidió volver ya casada con otro hombre
ya se la ve un poco de edad pero que
sigue y lo lindo en esta película este
documental es que la ves ahora baila
sentada ya no puede bailar parada pero
lo interesante es que los jóvenes que la
acompañan y que tocan la guitarra y le
hacen las palmas encantan no la pueden
seguir inclusive hoy el ritmo de sus
pies
es autodidacta era analfabeta y cuenta
que los 15 años 14 escucho el baile del
flamenco en la radio porque ella viene
de la época de ella me decía es muy
pobre es la guerra civil española que
termina cuando ella nació escuchó el
ritmo y se escondió después bajo las
sábanas para que su padre no la viera y
empezó con los dedos a marcar el ritmo
que sabía escuchar una radio y el
cerebro fue grabando todo y al día
siguiente se fue se puso sobre dos
ladrillos en su casa y empezó a hacer
con los pies con un espacio muy chiquito
de los ladrillos y eso es lo que estamos
viendo hoy esa manera exigente de
demostrar su arte y esa capacidad que
tuvo de salir adelante me impresiona me
me saco el sombrero ante esta nada y es
el arte pues el arte cura no entonces
pueden escuchar la entrevista que
tuviste con ella en nuestro centro
internet el título del artículo de la
del reportaje pues es la pasionaria del
flamenco a la que el machismo en la
comunidad gitana no pudo destruir bueno
buen título gracias me parece que eso
resume muy bien el tema que conversamos
con la charla
y louis los presentes el proceso de paz
en colombia que está en peligro si tuve
ocasión de entrevistar a chicha de
mariani que es conocido en colombia y en
el exterior como el hacker de la
fiscalía ya adriana petro que es la
hermana de gustavo petro ex candidato a
presidente de colombia que perdió las
últimas elecciones en junio
de 2018 a manos del actual presidente
iván duque lo que hizo el hacker la
fiscalía en su momento a comienzos del
año 2000 fue denunciar la infiltración
de grupos paramilitares en diversos
estamentos del gobierno colombiano
particularmente en la fiscalía por eso
él recibe este apodo el trabajaba en la
fiscalidad nacional de colombia pero él
sostiene que se infiltra de esa
infiltración alcanza a otros estamentos
como por ejemplo la agencia de
inteligencia el sistema penitenciario y
es esa que vemos ahí es como el momento
la todas las las bandas una ramificación
exacto que se fue creando de contactos
entre los grupos paramilitares y
funcionarios del gobierno nacional
colombiano que él pudo demostrar a
partir de diversa documentación entre
ella la agenda digital de un jefe
paramilitar que es conocido con el apodo
de 'el iguano' que en algún momento se
pudo acceder a la información de esa
agenda y en esa agenda de este jefe para
habilitar de un alto muy alto jefe
paramilitar
los teléfonos particulares de los
despachos de varios los más encumbrados
funcionarios del gobierno colombiano
entre los que veíamos ahora qué pasó con
esa información louis ese parece que es
muy delicada esa información esa
información sensible que es muy completa
muy vasta con una investigación que
abarcó dos o tres años y que se produjo
repito a comienzos del año 2000 ha sido
hasta hoy en día cajoneada eso es lo que
dice
adriana pero ella nos comenta que la
situación política en colombia ha no ha
variado en gran medida desde la época
del presidente uribe entre otras cosas
porque el poder reside aún en las mismas
manos puede haber cambiado de nombre que
se encuentre hoy al frente del poder
ejecutivo pero quienes gobiernan son
exactamente los mismos y ellos están
pidiendo de ahí la entrevista y de ahí
la presencia de ellos diana no aquí
efectivamente están pidiendo que
corte penal internacional interceda ante
el actual mandatario colombiano para que
desista de su idea de desconocer a lo
que se llaman la la jurisdicción
especial para la paz la j ep que son los
tribunales que se están encargando de
abordar la problemática de la violencia
por un lado de la guerrilla que los
grupos paramilitares y lo que quiera
hacer duque es pasar esas causas a la
justicia oficial por decirlo de alguna
manera pero esa justicia dicen tanto
riaño como petro sigue hasta hoy en día
infiltrada es decir se dejaría
a la solución a la que se podría llegar
no sería real sería parcial sería la
misma justicia que fue implicada en la
comisión de delitos la que decidiría
sobre este tipo de causas y eso haría
que
los acuerdos de paz al que se llegó en
colombia' corrieran serio peligro y que
se vuelva a épocas sangrientas como las
que vivió ese país durante prácticamente
50 años
louis que pasó con ry año s me imagino
que tiene una información tan sensible
que tal vez su vida también pueda correr
peligro obviamente tuvo que abandonar
colombia y hoy es un refugiado en canadá
en vancouver como adriana petro vive en
montreal es aceptar refugiar a los dos
viven aquí en cada de adriana petro en
en montreal de año en vancouver y el
último dato que agregó porque sé que nos
queda mucho tiempo
cuando el año pasado antes de las
elecciones hubo un atentado en contra
que gustavo petro las autoridades
colombianas dijeron que se trató de un
ataque con piedras contra el auto
blindado del entonces candidato a la
presidencia que tenía blindaje nivel
cinco esto es uno de los puntajes más
altos que existe en materia de casi
imposible de perforar con una piedra o
una piedra y el auto quedó totalmente
apoyado
el hacker la fiscalía llevó a cabo una
pericia veíamos un gráfico recién con
ondas sonoras esa pericia que se revisó
sobre el ataque al auto de gustavo petro
y esa pericia demostró que se trató de
balas
[Música]
como otros que han sucedido en américa
latina y yo les presentó esta semana un
reportaje una entrevista de hecho con
valeria massa tu él es masa tú él es un
fotoperiodista que también trabaja en
varios de los diarios de circulación
local en montreal particularmente él
presentó proyecto que se llama gran no
el lejano norte pero no habla del lejano
norte en el ártico sino el lejano norte
aquí en la ciudad de montreal que es un
barrio así lo nombra el lejano norte de
montreal que es el barrio montreal norte
que se conoció no lo conocemos nosotros
también en parte por la muerte de freddy
villanueva en 2008 me parece si en 2008
es un barrio donde hay una gran
concentración de inmigrantes
prácticamente y es uno de los más pobres
de canadá sí no
más pobre según algunos indicios que
encontramos por ahí y valeria en este
fotógrafo fue al barrio para quitarle
esa etiqueta de pobre y de violento y
darle una etiqueta de la de la vida
comunitaria mostrar como el barrio ha
cambiado en los últimos 50 años hizo un
ejercicio muy particular tomó fotos
antiguas y las le pidió a la gente del
barrio de hoy que las reproducirá y en
color
mente entonces y también con las
realidades de la gente del barrio de hoy
son tu ex y entonces una entrevista con
este fotógrafo que además lo que lo que
nos decía es que hay que ver cómo cambió
a montreal norte en los últimos 50 años
porque dice del de antes hace 50 años
era una zona donde todavía se cultivaba
comida era pero una forma más agrícola
aún agrícola y jugaron empleamos y ahora
está tan llena de vida tan llena de
proyectos la sociedad la comunidad está
muy unida tienen cosas en común entonces
es muy interesante esta conversación y
claro la entrevista que hicimos en vídeo
está un poco esparcida con imágenes
proyecto de valeria massa tour y un poco
la explicación sobre la muerte de este
joven de origen latinoamericano bajo las
balas de los polis violencia posición y
que sigue habiendo mucha contaminación
no quiere decir que no haya violencia en
ese barrio no sea un barrio con
complicaciones pero en todo caso lo que
quiere decir en el fondo me parece a mí
y además la de la diversidad étnica y la
diversidad cultural de la gente que vive
ahí lo hace un barrio riquísimo en
muchos sentidos no nada más un barrio
pobre nada no nada más un barrio con
dificultades entonces ese es el tema de
microbios o del [ __ ] sí y lo largo que
está hoy presentándonos ayudándonos digo
desde allá dentro de la cabina él
presenta una crónica en tecnología sobre
se pregunta en realidad si facebook y
sus y sus su posicionamiento contra el
supremacismo blanco esta semana es una
estrategia
reales sería para que el marketing de
realmente correctamente o adecuadamente
usted decidió días pasados de esa finca
del sitio internet de un supremacista
blanco y la duda que plantea el artículo
es si se trata de una decisión que tiene
que ver realmente con convicciones
respecto de ese tema o si es una
búsqueda de decir no nosotros tenemos en
consideración intereses de la sociedad
realidad nos sigue interesando el dinero
como zion entonces leonardo aquí menos
se hace esta gran pregunta y a partir de
mañana van a ver algunas de las
respuestas a las que las que pudo llegar
no a partir de animación no porque
acuérdate que las agónicas de tecnología
no los entran los abandono de un amigo
de la mañana pero la pueden acceder en
nuestro sitio internet y bueno ya nos
estamos yendo pero no sin antes
justamente agradecerle a leonardo gimeno
que haya estado esta vez de aquel lado
aunque lo extrañamos de este lado pero
no había lugar éramos muchos el problema
se está haciendo otro tipo de trabajo
con el inicio que tenemos
nuevos medios esenciales porque lo
necesitamos también allá en esta en esta
nueva etapa exactamente también le
agradezco a benoit rioja y a marc andrey
de sión que son los otros dos técnicos
que están trabajando de aquel lado de la
cabina
muchas gracias leonora gracias próximo
nos estaremos hasta la próxima viendo
porque ahora se escucha viendo la
próxima semana hasta luego
[Música]